va beh
bella katy ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo ios anno fa vj ed oggi siamo
tornati sul mi sono preso veramente
troppo bene questo gioco qua e ho fatto
un paio di partite nel mentre che la
settimana scorsa fino adesso ho fatto un
po di più
cosa ho fatto
[Musica]
qualcosa fanno per me basta ciò non è
possibile
ho fatto un sacco di partite dall'ultima
volta che ho fatto il video ad adesso ma
in tutte queste sacco di partite non mi
è mai successa una cosa mai
no no non è possibile ragazzi ma che
cazzo succede ma serio
guarda lo sai che bordello non è
possibile a carissimo posso diventato un
fenomeno a caso proprio così niente
ragazzi poi io direi che posso
concludere quel video già fatto tutto
quello che dovevo fare cioè tua madre
[ __ ] perché mi è tornato su facebook
perché mi ha aperto una foto di johnny
creek ricominciava questo video cosa
cazzo è successo nel primo minuto di
video è successo di tutto non ho capito
niente comunque ragazzuoli ho guardato
un paio di tattiche e robe c'è il
cercato di capire latino come funziona
ed è veramente ma proprio tanto figo sto
qua a differenza di agar io che mi fa
cagare proprio perché se c'è una roba
che ho capito è che una tattica che non
ho mai cambiato e continuare a seguire
quelli grossi perché quelli grossi danni
punti grossi sempre che non abbiano la
mamma che batte in autostrada però
quella un altro discorso
ah ah ah ah certo vorreste uccidermi e
brutto ed efficiente cosa è successo
come quanta gente morta ma non è vero
non sono stato ucciso da morte morte
morte
liz donk il mit ma poverino non puoi
chiamarti così però è scusami se ti
chiami così mi stai istigando pure tu
deficiente sai che succede morte morto o
chiara casuale dai adesso cerchiamo di
resistere un attimino senza morire per
l'amor di dio che ok che così in cura da
solo vai vai vai vai che simula inculati
niente o non è morto no no no fini così
[Musica]
meno male fatto e quanto è lungo ci sono
tutti e vabbè quanti punti ciao ragazzi
alla prossima dai vai vai bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye prendi prendi roba
prendi roba prendilo la prendilo caprini
roma 3 nov
quanta roba sto prendendo lo il culo lo
in culo nel senso che gli sono andato
sul culo che cursori nato sono rinato
riuscire un morto aveva e questa cosa
veramente cool incredibile ragazzi no no
no no no no dai togliti dai [ __ ]
errori doverne rosa che palle che ci fa
questo scemo preso male ti devi togliere
deficienti ma cosa vuole e kakà palle
adesso è adesso e ha detto è di crepare
male ragazzi 5.000 cinquemila è arrivato
a 5.000 incredibile un server in atto
così avanti non mi devo distrarre
ragazzi sono diventato grosso
quartiere in non so quanti pezzi come
l'ho ucciso ho rischiato tantissimo
parola ucciso importante quello di pippo
pippo non puoi chiamarti pippo illegali
in italia a chiamarsi pippo fa quello
sistema già un po dio perfetto grande la
madonna quanto fatto sono cinque organi
sfondi vr 5.000 devo stare zitto perchè
ogni volta mi porto sfiga che la metà
basta però ok
porca merda non son riuscito a ucciderlo
professori sco si è fatta
non ci credo mai dal fratello è questo
ed efficiente e vero ho visto delle
tattiche su internet e so come uccide ti
devo stringere sempre di più cerchio per
quanto guarda i punti li porca merda
e vabbè non ci credo mai mai nella vita
sì però sede ed efficiente che palle ma
perché lì si apre facebook e cazzo me ne
frega di gazzarrini dobbiamo cambiare
nome ragazzi e quello che non funziona
facciamo a poco come un deficit vuole
morti più stupide boschi e vabbè mi
fotte tutte lui brutto bastardo va bene
in quanto era grosso per quanto ci ha
fatto 10 giri nicchia come vi si sono
salvati sti due veloce veloce l'ho ce
l'ho ce l'ho ce l'ho certo ormai che non
aveva visto nessuno no al comicon
brasiliano c'è il pitone brasiliano
ragazzi e grosso abbiamo appurato in
questo momento ecco perché promuove il
bordello di punti torna a me poi figlio
di la nile è certo beh allora picchia
ragazzo non volendo tutti tutti adesso
sono a 6400 punti di quasi 7.000 punti
sono più grosso che mai questa frase
molto importante per me che sono uomo
che è il vero che mi chiamo bieber
quindi prima si arriva prima a fare la
scritta bieber è primo per entrare in
classifica deve arrivare almeno al
doppio della mia lunghezza di me che mi
deve morire un gigante davanti per per
arrivare primo parah parah questo come
si chiama
l'ultima scegli tra un nome decente o
madonna sopra r6 schiattato to stronzo
sono riuscito a ucciderlo non so con per
culo però a tanti ragazzi quando diventi
grossissimo ti muovi pure lento perché
adesso in bim sono lenti una donna l'ho
visto a brutti ho partorito un bambino
fatemi uscire dal suo posto de merda ve
prego mv [ __ ] questo brutto
deficiente vai vai vai vai vai prendilo
punti 10.000 diecimila pro dove arrivare
a 11 con te 10.008 dai dai gare si sono
in classifica sono no no sono no no sono
ruolo di meri cari esso decimo bper in
classifica decimo 600 persone
fantastiche non è il massimo posto al
quale sia marian è arrivato su sneijder
io mai arrivato così avanti
figlio di tua madre che si deve infilare
nel deretani vermi edizione no no no no
è già un traguardo mondiale sono
arrivato nono va bene ma va ragazzi e li
fare l'ultima perché sennò diventa
veramente troppo lungo non li verme la
partita tra i primi dieci fatto fuori da
un nano che non era più grosso di quanto
sono io adesso amiche chi l'aveva vista
vedere a ok allora c'è americana c'è
quella italiana
eccola qua era caduta proprio questa e
quella arcobaleno e poi ci sono quelle
strane tipo questa quella che dice
eccola questa qui non capivo io
minchia fatemelo a usare che è bella e
cazzuta non capivo sta roba delle skin
era da una vita che capiti cercava di
capire come prenderle meno male c'era il
tasto so io sorbo non vedo niente tu ce
l'hai codino e zia no io sono più figo
ah ah ah no vediamo se riusciamo a fare
un po di è perfetto lo sapevo io ti è
morto anche lui è morto anche lui morto
anche vittoria ma dietro ma intanto che
sono lì poi prende brutto deficiente
sono miei sono miei
oddio visto troppi punti troppi punti
troppi punti troppi punti toglierebbe
alla sise in egoista sia un egoista
maledetto neanche quelli mai lasciato
interviste troll questi chiama troll
ecco visto se non avessi toccato prima a
quest'ora resti vivo non ci ho voluto
risparmiare e neanche a te brutto devi
cento è un grandissimo quanti punti oggi
sono partito dopo un minuto sto
diventate oggi dantesco di sono morti
tutti davanti solo perché quel tipo ha
tentato di rubarmi punti e sono cool
cats lo uccide hawkeye al karma ragazzi
esistere
grandissimo no cosa come cosa succeda il
processo perché vi sia aperta l'altra
pagina per quale motivo ma che cazzo già
sto mouse allora addio cerca mini non lo
so abramo lincoln su wikipedia
no no no quello non abramo lincoln
abramo lincoln e ragazzi concluso che
l'episodio è stato costruttivo veramente
un nipote giocasta roba sempre
costruttivo oggi alla gente che mi
uccide quanto lo ammazzerei vabbè
comunque ragazzi spero che video vi sia
piaciuto concludo che episodio come se
ci è piaciuto a suo documento è un mi
piace è capace di facebook e come di
ridotto trascrizione sono stati
fischiati anni ci fidiamo lo fossero
vito bello ragazzi